yes comic-con is over in the masters of
the web comic-con panel was badass what
did i do i stood in no lines I saw no
reveals I literally walked around for
three days as a Comic Con was going on
and I met you guys I met fans I got like
that just thoroughly entertained me
thank you all I met fans and I was like
I have cool fans no one was a dickbag
everyone was nice everyone who y'all
just had a good time talking speaking of
talking you know you guys want me to
talk about this [ __ ] today I go online
and I see there is a trailer for The
Hobbit the Battle of the five armies
that we gonna talk about that absolutely
because it's The Hobbit the trailers
really cool I mean it has that really
eerie somber tone real like yeah this is
the conclusion of a trilogy alright and
you see smile come down just calm we're
in the town right there as before I was
like bard was pretty right the
desolation of smaug bard was like don't
go up there because you're gonna destroy
us all he's gonna come down and kick our
ass so what a snout do he comes down and
kicks their ass job Bard you called it
they're actually dicks for not listening
to you you were right and for me
actually as the Smaug thing ends that's
where my knowledge of the Hobbit ends
sir sighs that's where I remember it
ending as a kid it's like Oh smile good
that's that Battle of five armies I know
nothing about that if the trailer fills
me in on what I need to know which is
pretty much like hey this is why you
want to watch it because it's called The
Hobbit something or other you got to
give this trailer props for one thing
they're like all right we have to play
one song in the trailer what's the song
you know the song the song when Fire
Amir was writing to us Gilly outs with
his army and he's gonna get about a
thousand arrows shoved up his ass and
Ditka throws all like yo sing me a song
so peeping out of thin air is like oh I
guess this song will sound pretty epic
and badass is how we do it this Shire I
guess if you're singing that song it's
really sad and everything slung on
you're like oh man this kills me yeah
that song in this trailer really the
armies are getting together and war is
happening this is just how it's going
down now one series like you can have
peace or you can have war so one oak and
chills all like I'll have war I was like
foreign man we're gonna saw him in the
last movie just kind of be stressed out
he's like no Bilbo you're a burglar and
I'm not gonna risk this [ __ ] for you
it's gonna dick out it's gonna slice up
elves as cabinets or lick spines and
kitchen don't like Elvis spines it's bad
for your image in middle-earth I really
do get from this trailer why they
changed the title to the Battle of the
five armies it was gonna be the hobbit
there and back again I just cannot
imagine that [ __ ] here you imagine that
I'll have war war Bam Bam he's getting
sliced
Maddog hahaha bye-bye Manu Bennett from
the Masters of the web come come panel
that I was on you can check it out
there's just death and I swing the sword
boom I had Sauron and then the Hobbit
they're in back again no I think the
Battle of the five armies is a perfect
title for those one plenteous I'm
looking forward to I'm going to see the
concluding chapter of the Hobbit trilogy
and the last movie of The Lord of the
Rings middle-earth saga this trailer
literally could have been Bilbo all like
I have a belly button
so this trailer didn't have to sell me
how much they played it smart though
good tone great trailer shit's going
down great song from a great moment from
a great movie great trailer music man
that makes a trailer to The Hobbit the
Battle of the five armies have you seen
the teaser trailer and what did you
think about it every thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more